begin this half hour with the nation's
symbol under a new threat america's bald
eagles have soared back from the brink
of extinction unchecked hunting and the
widespread use of pesticides sharply cut
their population in the 20th century but
in the last decade their numbers have
quadrupled now avian flew and leadpoll's
new risk to the bald eagle and other
birds of prey charlie demar visited one
wildlife center that's trying to help
any little move you do
they're just suspicious of it jacques
nuzzo's mission is to heal broken birds
of prey she was a juvenile
literally was laying in a guy's gutter
on his house at the illinois raptors
center the goal is to get every bird
back into the wild good job
some will never leave she had multiple
issues so but lead was one of those
issues this is a male others aren't as
lucky it's hard to see something so
powerful majestic become so weak
and helpless just make sure there's
nothing broken 38 bald eagles have been
brought in since 2018. we're going to
check for any lead fragments half have
shown alarming levels of lead
died from lead poisoning three died this
march alone including one the day before
our visit
eagles and vultures are scavengers
cleaning up what nature leaves behind
they feast on the remains left by
hunters if there's just a little bit of
that lead from that ammunition in there
and that's where the eagles get it from
that's where the vultures get it from so
something as small as one bb is enough
to kill an eagle yes
as far as yeah lead light toxicity goes
yeah so here's the
plasma samples travis wilcoxson is
chairman of the biology department at
nearby millikin university and he's on
the raptor center board he and nuzo
decided to start testing all the birds
brought in some of the birds that really
started to catch our eye were birds that
do not scavenge these are birds that
actively hunt live prey
like cooper's hawk and the eastern
screech owl we definitely see a lot of
lead in these guys they were surprised
to find that a third of the raptors they
treated like these cooper's hawks and
screech owls showed high levels of lead
so they decided to test the birds they
prey on
like pigeons and robins they found
alarming levels of lead there too to us
that said
there's something in the environment
that these birds are exposed to likely
in these urban settings
we're probably exposed to that too this
might be a record for us
a grim one yeah it is lead's devastating
impact on these birds a stark reminder
of the dangers it still presents to all
of us
for cbs saturday morning charlie demar
decatur illinois
majestic birds overall they're doing
great quadrupling quadrupling in
population in the lower 48 in the last
14 years but again as he just said it's
a reminder threats still exist metals
saying the canary in the coal mine right
might be an indicator of what could
happen to us so beware